this video is titled why Singapore
mathematics and I think that's also a
very good question there are a number of
things about Singapore mathematics that
are difficult and a little bit that are
seemed to be counterintuitive when you
first look at it why are there so many
word problems why do I have to use all
of these crazy manipulatives why are
there so many pictures what do I do with
all of these strange bar models right
and I think what you know a lot of those
sort of sum up to why can't we just
learn math the way math has always been
learned hasn't math isn't math Universal
doesn't it never change if it was good
enough for me back when I learned it why
isn't it good enough now and I think
those are good questions and I'd refer
to some of the other videos about how we
use some of these manipulatives but I
think there's a real value in this
Singapore mathematics teaching style
just pedagogically and I think it starts
with why what students struggle with
about math right and I think the way
that's the reason why students or anyone
struggles with mathematics is
mathematics requires a shift from what
we might call the concrete over to the
abstract all right and you can see this
as just as an example if I have
something like three books here right
this is concrete I can hold in my hand
this is a real-world real-life problem
here right and if I want to model this
right but what we do numerically is we
make a shift from the three books here
right over to just representing them by
the number three right I think this is a
very difficult ship for students it's
hugely important right this is one of
the reasons why we do teach mathematics
is it help students think to say I'm
gonna take something that's a real-world
problem something that's you know in the
concrete realm and I'm gonna use
mathematics to abstract it so that I can
deal with it right if I'm gonna add
three books took like seven books I
don't want to have to like put three
books get three books out get seven more
books out and combine them all and then
count how many books I had right but I
really want to be able to do in
mathematics is to take the three and add
it to a seven and use the symbols right
so that's why we want to teach
mathematics but the shift is actually
very difficult for students right
abstracting something especially if you
put your kids in their first grade
second
third grade it's actually a skill they
don't have right this seems to adults oh
of course we would use that symbol to
model that reality but for students this
is a struggle right and this is a big
leap over into the abstract the
brilliance of Singapore mathematics lies
in the ability to take something to help
students make this shift right so to go
from the concrete to the abstract what
we do is we have them pass through the
pictorial write that we use this as
something that is an easy way to shift
from the concrete to the abstract it's
somewhere in the middle right it's not
concrete it's not abstract but it
participates in them a little bit of
both and it's universal right everyone's
actually able to draw pictures and
that's actually the reason why Singapore
Math got invented in the first place is
when the country of Singapore shipped
its lifted its language of instruction
to English right students had a hard
time grappling with this new language
and so what they did was they inserted a
bunch of pictures into their mathematics
program in order to help students make
sense of it right think of mathematics
as students learning the language of
mathematics these pictures really end up
helping so what I could do is draw
something you know that's not a very
good book but you get what I'm saying
here if I draw that this is not really
it's not concrete right they're not
physical things I can hold they're not
abstract and that's not just a symbol
but they're a way to make a transition
here right from the concrete to the
abstract okay and you might be thinking
well I don't need three books here to
make that transition right but so how
does this actually play out in there in
a real problem here right pretend if I
have a concrete problem maybe I have 19
students and then I get 12 more right
I'm not gonna have the concrete students
up here all right but you have to
imagine them physically standing here
with me right and I want to know how
many students I have in total right and
what I want students to be able to do
all right is over here in the abstract
realm where I have 19 plus 12 and I take
my 9 plus 2 is 11 and one plus one plus
one is three and I want you to be able
to get my answer of 31 in the abstract
alright but this is a big leap for
students right they can count over here
write this they've got to do this symbol
[ __ ] around the relationships here
right around the you're taking these
symbols you're moving them all around
and this is very difficult right this is
actually this seems very natural to us
as adults but it's actually very
difficult for students here
and so how do I get a student to
progress from over here where they're
just counting to be able to do an
operation like this well I want to
figure out what picture I can draw and
so what we do is we draw a picture like
this where I can say hey I have tens and
I have ones here and 19 students is made
up of one ten and nine ones and twelve
students is made up of one ten and two
ones and what I want to do is push these
two things together in order to get the
31 right and so now you can imagine
either drawing a picture or using a
manipulative here taking these ten ones
and grouping them into one 10 and now I
can count at the end and I can see okay
I have three tens and one one and I can
see the thirty one show up here so what
I've done is I've used a picture to be
the thing that my students can progress
through 19 and 19 students plus twelve
students through this understanding
right to understand why this works how
to do this how this isn't just a random
rearrangement of symbols process but how
you actually use the understanding of
the concepts to make sense so when you
think about why are all these crazy
things about Singapore in here right why
are these ten frames why are these
manipul why are these bar models it's in
this realm it's in these pictures that
we help students to learn how to draw so
that they can make sense of the most
difficult thing in mathematics
which is the progression from the
concrete in the abstract